there is a form of therapy which is
right now in most countries of the world
illegal but which stands to become a
dominant way of doing therapy over the
coming years and may be the Principal
route by which many people will heal
from their traumas
the reason why psychedelic therapy is
likely to prove so important is that it
has the power to overcome the central
impediment to successful therapy right
now
fundamental thesis of psychotherapy is
that we grow ill because there are
things inside our minds that we have not
been able to confront feel and think
about and which reside in the
unconscious from where they create
vicious disturbances symptoms neuroses
hysteria for our conscious selves
classically the task of therapy has been
to provide a safe and welcoming Forum in
which a patient can feel relaxed enough
to let the therapist into their
imaginations and then make sense of the
knots and troubles that lie there what
Freud called the fundamental rule of
psychotherapy is that one should be
wholly honest with the therapist in
Sharing whatever happens to enter one's
mind never leave anything out because
for some reason or other it is
unpleasant to tell it he advised this
sounds important but there is one
enormous problem most people are
entirely unable when it comes to it to
let down their guard sufficiently to
tell the therapist whatever they are
feeling the therapy and possibilities of
healing are disrupted by our defenses
this is where psychedelic substances
offer hope a chemical compound like MDMA
does not intoxicate in any simple way it
doesn't like wine or vodka Place one
into a relaxed stupor it keeps the Mind
highly alert and clear-eyed while at the
same time lifting the mechanisms of
repression it allows one to think and
feel but also not be afraid or inhibited
the mind can feel brave enough to go to
places it would normally shun also for
reasons not yet known to scientists it
gives one an appetite for
self-exploration when taken in the right
setting in a quiet room with music eye
shades and usually the presence of a
kind and curious therapist we give
ourselves the chance which we might have
avoided for many years to think about
tricky aspects of our psyche that need
our attention we may stumble on a
powerful need to reflect on a period of
childhood a figure from our past or a
difficulty we had scarcely ever dwelt on
at the same time because we are
uninhibited we don't mind sharing the
material we might write it down speak it
into our phone or tell the therapist in
this way we are able to bring to the
surface a rare kind of psychological or
pure undistorted and connected up with
all our major neurotic symptoms
MDMA is currently illegal all over the
world and can only be experienced in
certain safe clinical settings but it
holds out the promise that it will one
day make Psychotherapy work as well as
it always should have done
the School of Life offers online
Psychotherapy to people all around the
world our therapists are highly trained
and accredited and are a vital source of
kindness Solace and wisdom for life's
most difficult moments click the link to
find out more